New R-S-P-R-A-C-H-E or Stalker Verius Kroen. Everybody knows that effort matters. What was revelatory to me was how much it mattered. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantin. What is it that makes extraordinary people successful? Is it talent, genius, luck? Or is Angela Duckworth suggests? Is it grit?, is a grit.
New R-S-P-R-A-C-H-E 或 Stalker Verius Kroen。每个人都知道努力很重要。对我而言有启发意义的是，努力究竟有多重要。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹丁。是什么让非凡的人获得成功？是天赋、天才、运气吗？还是正如安吉拉·达克沃斯所说的那样？是坚毅吗？是坚毅吗？
There is a fluency and an ease with which true mastery and expertise always expresses itself whether it be in writing, whether it be in a mathematical proof, but I think the question is, you know, where does that fluency and mastery come from? Today on Hidden Brain, we explore this quality that Angela says is responsible for so much excellence and achievement. And then we ask, does grit also have a downside? Sometimes people with high grit might not do the logical, rational thing because they're grit compels them to keep going. Angela Dacqua is a psychology professor at the University of Pennsylvania. She first became interested in grit while working as a math teacher for middle school and high school students.
真正的精通和专业知识在表达时总是流畅而轻松的，无论是写作还是数学证明，但我觉得问题在于，这种流畅和精通从何而来？今天在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们探讨安吉拉所说的成就卓越和伟大成就背后的这种品质。然后我们探究，坚毅也有不好的一面吗？有时，具有高坚毅度的人可能不会做符合逻辑、理性的事，因为他们的坚毅驱使他们坚持下去。安吉拉·达克沃斯是宾夕法尼亚大学的心理学教授。她最初对坚毅产生兴趣是在为中学生和高中生担任数学老师期间。
Angela told me that when she started teaching, she noticed right away which kids were the quickest learners, the most naturally talented you might say. These were the kids who, when she explained the concept once, were immediately raising their hands to answer questions. You know, I immediately thought to myself as a young and, you know, wrong teacher that, okay, those are the kids by the end of the year are going to have progressed the farthest. Because I had other kids for whom it's like, I put up the first problem, I showed to them, I put up the second problem, I showed them a different way,
安吉拉告诉我，她刚开始教书时，立刻就注意到哪些孩子学得最快，也就是人们所说最有天赋的孩子。这些孩子当她解释一遍概念后，就会立刻举手回答问题。你知道的，作为一个年轻且（你知道的）经验不足的老师，我当时立刻心想，好吧，这些孩子到学年末将会取得最大的进步。因为我还有其他孩子，对于他们来说，当我摆出第一道题，我展示给他们看，我摆出第二道题，我用另一种方法展示给他们，
I sit down with them, and okay, the fourth time, the fifth time, and it's not I put up the first problem, I showed to them, I put up the second problem, I show them a different way, I sit down with them, and okay the fourth time, the fifth time, and it's not as easy for them. I thought well those kids are destined to be at the very bottom of the class, and I'm not saying that that wasn't at all true. There were some quick learners who did well, and there were some kids for whom math was more difficult who did poorly, but there were more exceptions that I could have ever imagined. By the end of the year, when I looked at the final grades and I thought, wow, you know, this girl, this boy,
我和他们坐在一起，然后，第四次、第五次，情况并非如此——我摆出第一道题，我展示给他们看，我摆出第二道题，我用另一种方法展示给他们，我和他们坐在一起，然后第四次、第五次，事情对他们来说没有那么容易。我想，好吧，这些孩子注定要在班里垫底，我并不是说这完全不符合事实。有一些学得快且表现不错的孩子，也有一些觉得数学更难而表现不佳的孩子，但例外情况比我能想象的还要多。到学年末，当我看着最终成绩时，我想，哇，你知道的，这个女孩，这个男孩，
wow, they did a lot better than I thought they were gonna do and gosh, you know, these other kids, so I thought we're gonna do fantastically well. Hmm, they didn't do well. So I think that the thing that was revelatory to me was not that effort matters. Everybody knows that effort matters. What was revelatory to me was not that effort matters. Everybody knows that effort matters. What was revelatory to me was how much it mattered.
哇，他们比我想象的要表现得好得多，天哪，你知道的，其他这些我们以为会表现得极其出色的孩子。嗯，他们表现得并不好。所以我想，对我有启发意义的并不是努力很重要。每个人都知道努力很重要。对我而言有启发意义的并不是努力很重要。每个人都知道努力很重要。对我而言有启发意义的是努力究竟有多重要。
Since her days as a schoolteacher, Angela has made an academic career of studying this one character trait. And that is grid, the combination of passion and perseverance for very long-term goals. I found it interesting that Angela focused on the subject, because in our society it seems that there is this image of the genius Who doesn't really have to work very hard? I think the popular imagination has it right and wrong I think if you have the intuition that somebody like Einstein or Picasso that they you know had a certain
自从当学校老师的日子以来，安吉拉就把研究这种单一的人格特质作为了她的学术生涯。这就是坚毅，对极其长远的目标所保持的热情与坚持的结合。我发现安吉拉关注这个课题很有意思，因为在我们的社会中，似乎存在着这样一种天才的形象：他们其实不需要付出太多努力？我认为大众的想象既对又错。如果你有这样一种直觉，即像爱因斯坦或毕加索那样，他们（你知道的）拥有某种
ability or a sensitivity a Sensibility, I think that's right. I don't think Einstein was just like another guy on the street and Norris Picasso. So I think having some intuition that there is an ability part of the achievement talent is one way to name that. I think that's right. I don't want to be the one to say that Einstein
能力、敏感度或悟性，我认为这没说错。我不认为爱因斯坦只是街上的另一个普通人，毕加索也不是。所以我认为，直觉上存在成就的天赋部分——天赋是命名这一点的途径之一。我认为这没有错。我不想成为那个说爱因斯坦
wasn't talented Norris Picasso. But that other thing that they did, which was to work furiously hard, with that kind of obsessive love for a very narrow and the end, you know, domain, in which they decided to go forward and not kind of diversify and do six things, 12 things. I think that's also important, and that second thing, you know, really being able to focus for a long time on something that you love and it's so Important to you that it kind of wakes you up every day and is the last thing you think about before you go to bed I think that's also true. So the popular intuition isn't wildly off. It's importantly incomplete
没有天赋，或者说毕加索没有天赋的人。但他们所做的另一件事，那就是以一种疯狂的努力工作，对一个非常狭窄的最终领域怀有一种强迫症般的爱，他们决定在这个领域前进，而不是去多元化地做6件事、12件事。我认为这也是很重要的，这第二件事，（你知道的）真正能够长时间专注于你所热爱的事物，并且它对你如此重要，以至于它每天把你唤醒，也是你睡觉前想的最后一件事，我认为这也是真的。所以大众的直觉并没有离谱到极点，只是在重要方面不够完整。
One of the most interesting things Angela told me is that it might be a psychological reason why we want to think of genius as being effortless. There is a fluency and an ease with which true mastery and expertise always expresses itself, whether it be in writing, whether it be in a mathematical proof, whether it be in a dance that you see on stage, really in every domain. But I think the question is, where does that fluency and mastery come from? And those hours and hours of laborious effort, of misfires, of poorly written drafts,
安吉拉告诉我的最有趣的事情之一是，我们想要将天才视为不费吹灰之力的，这背后可能存在着一种心理原因。真正的精通和专业知识在表达时总是流畅而轻松的，无论是写作，还是数学证明，还是你在舞台上看到的舞蹈，实际上在各个领域都是如此。但我觉得问题在于，这种流畅和精通从何而来？而那些长年累月艰苦的努力、失败的尝试、写得糟糕的草稿、
of falling on your butt when you're trying to do a turn, those things are hidden. And I think there's motivation for the performer to hide that. So if I showed you, Sean Carmye, 197 drafts of the manuscript that finally got produced, what effect would that have when you then read the 198 draft? Nietzsche, the German philosopher, said that when there is excellence, if we know when it became,
当你想做一个转身时却摔了个屁股蹲儿，这些事情都被隐藏起来了。我认为表演者有隐藏这些的动机。所以如果我向你展示，肖恩·卡米，最后制作出来的手稿的197个草稿，当你随后阅读第198个草稿时，会产生什么影响？德国哲学家尼采曾说过，当卓越出现时，如果我们知道它起源于何时，
if we know it's messy origins, we immediately grow cool, Nietzsche said, we wanted to come out of the ground as if by magic. And I think the motivation from the performer has a parallel motivation from the audience. You know, why does the audience want to hide the effort? Here in Nietzsche had a very observant insight, which is to say that if we believe that what you can do is because you have a gift that I don't do Here in each of says I do not have to compete here. The audience can relax shoulders back sit into your chair And just marvel at something where you don't even have any obligation to try yourself to match the performance
如果我们知道它杂乱的起源，我们就会立刻冷淡下来。尼采说，我们希望它像变魔术一样从地下钻出来。我认为表演者的这种动机与观众的动机有着相似之处。你知道的，为什么观众想要隐藏这种努力？在这里，尼采有一个非常有洞察力的见解，那就是如果我们相信你所能做到的只是因为你拥有我所没有的天赋——在这里尼采说我不需要竞争，在这里观众可以放松肩膀，靠在椅背上，只需惊叹于某种你甚至没有义务亲自去尝试匹配这种表现的事物。
That is so interesting So in other words when you present geniuses being effortless at some level It's more pleasurable to the audience than if you present geniuses being the product of very, very hard work. I think that's absolutely true. I mean, one of my favorite thinkers on this topic is a sociologist at Hamilton named Dan Chamblis. Now Dan is, you know, well into adulthood now, but he was a competitive swimmer all throughout
这太有趣了。换句话说，当你把天才呈现为不费吹灰之力时，在某种程度上，比起把天才呈现为非常非常努力工作的产物，它更能让观众感到愉悦。我认为这绝对是真的。我的意思是，我最喜欢研究这个主题的思想家之一是汉密尔顿学院的一位社会学家，名叫丹·钱布利斯。现在丹（你知道的）已经步入成年，但他整个
high school into college and even in his first couple of years I think of being an assistant professor was still coaching and he spent six years with swimmers at all levels of you know from the local club swim team to You know Olympic hopefuls and I think one of the things that he you know Observe that surprised him was that how how Excellence is really the confluence of many, many, many small acts. Each of them doable, each of them able to be honed with practice. When you put it all together, there is a kind of mystery to it or a magic to it. He titled his article on this, The Mundaneity of Excellence, to suggest that really, if you
高中到大学乃至我担任助理教练头几年都是一名竞技游泳运动员，他与各水平的游泳运动员共度了六年时间，从当地的俱乐部游泳队到（你知道的）奥运会希望之星。我认为他（你知道的）观察到并令他感到惊讶的一件事是，卓越实际上是如何成为众多微小行为的汇聚。其中的每一个行为都是可行的，每一个都可以通过练习来磨练。当你把它们放在一起时，其中有一种神秘感或魔术感。他关于这篇的文章题为《卓越的平凡》，旨在表明实际上，如果你
ask the question when it became, you do get to this kind of like oh okay 10,000 small acts each of them Very doable none of them terribly interesting But when I was talking to him more recently about his older work He started to describe what it was like to watch spits the great, you know, American swimmers And he said you know when you when you got into the pool I mean it was like it was like he was a fish and I could hear the awe in his voice It was you, like describing somebody who really was super human.
问它起源于何时的问题，你确实会接触到这种诸如“哦，好吧，一万个微小的行为，每一个都非常可行，没有一个特别有趣”的东西。但当我最近与他谈论他的旧工作时，他开始描述观看施皮茨这位伟大的（你知道的）美国游泳运动员时的感受，他说，你知道的，当你进入泳池时，我的意思是，那感觉就像他是一条鱼，我能听到他声音中的敬畏。你就像是在描述一个真正超级人类的人。
And, you know, I think we both then had the insight that all of us, no matter what we study and how much we know intellectually that it is effort and it is practice. And, you know, there are many unglamorous hours that don't get caught on camera. We sort of have this, you know, craving for that magic and mystery.
而且，你知道的，我想我们俩当时都有这样一种顿悟，即我们所有人，无论我们研究什么，无论我们在知识上多么清楚这就是努力，这就是练习。而且，你知道的，有许多没有被镜头捕捉到的光鲜亮丽背后的漫长小时。我们有点（你知道的）渴望那种魔术和神秘感。
You did a study a few years ago that looked at winners of the spelling bee, and you discovered something about the students and young people who did very well in the spelling bee. What did you find? I did that study on the spelling bee finalists with a psychologist, probably well known to your listeners, named Anders Erickson, so the very popular version of his work
几年前你做过一项研究，调查了拼字比赛的优胜者，你发现了一些关于在拼字比赛中表现非常优秀的男女学生和年轻人的情况。你发现了什么？我和一位可能为你的听众所熟知的心理学家安德斯·埃里克森一起对拼字比赛的决赛选手进行了这项研究，所以他作品的最流行版本
is the 10,000 hour rule of practice. But what Anders would say, I think, in his own words, is that it's the quality of practice, in addition to the quantity that really matters. He calls the highest quality of practice, deliberate practice. And that's what he's found experts to do in all physical and intellectual domains that he's studied. So Anders and I got together and we asked a question
就是一万小时练习定律。但我想安德斯会用他自己的话说，除了数量之外，真正重要的是练习的质量。他将最高质量的练习称为刻意练习。这也是他在他研究过所有身体和知识领域中发现专家们所做的事情。所以安德斯和我聚在一起，我们提出了一个问题
which is what is the kind of practice that kids who are in the national spelling B finals do? What kinds of things do they do? And which of these kinds of practice activities is the most effective? And what personality traits predict what kind of practice kids will engage in? So we found is that kids do three things
，那就是全国拼字比赛决赛中的孩子们会进行什么样的练习？他们会做哪些类型的事情？在这些练习活动中，哪一种最有效？以及什么样的人格特质能预测孩子们会参与哪种练习？所以我们发现孩子们做三件事
to win the spelling bee broadly. They read a lot, which they love to do, and they rated about as effortless and as about as enjoyable as eating ice cream. They also get quizzed by mom or dad, you know, by computer. So your mom says, Usbaka, you say,
来赢得拼字比赛，大体上是这样的。他们阅读大量书籍，这是他们最喜欢做的事，他们将其评为像吃冰淇淋一样毫不费力且同样令人愉悦。他们还会接受妈妈或爸爸（你知道的）或计算机的测验。所以你妈妈说：乌斯巴卡，你说，
Usbaka, you are SPRA, CH-H-E, Urspraka, which I believe is a crack spelling and is certainly the winning word for the year that we studied Spellers. And then the final thing that we categorize from like looking at the journals that we ask kids to sort of keep something of a diary just to tell us what kinds of things they were doing
乌斯巴卡，是 U-S-P-R-A，C-H-H-E，Urspraka，我相信这是一种正确的拼写，并且绝对是我们研究拼字选手的那一年中的获胜单词。然后我们分类的最后一件事是，通过查看我们要求孩子们保留的一些日记，让他们告诉我们他们正在做样的事情、
and how long they were doing and how it felt. And the last category would be deliberate practice, usually done alone, working on things that you can't do, like word origins that are not familiar to you, trying to respel words and write vertically on a page, words that you've misspelled before, the honing in on your weaknesses that is really crucial to the kind of deliberate practice that Anders has found in other experts. And what we found is that the quantity of deliberate practice was far more predictive of how far you would actually get in final competition when you compare it
他们做了多久以及感觉如何。最后一个类别将是刻意练习，通常是独自完成，攻克你做不到的事情，比如你不熟悉的词源，试图重新拼写单词并在一页纸上垂直书写你以前拼错的单词，专注于你的弱点，这对于安德斯在其他专家身上发现的那种刻意练习至关重要。我们发现，当你将刻意练习与其他两种练习进行比较时，刻意练习的数量更能预测你在最终比赛中能走多远。
to the other two kinds of practice. And the phenomenology that's a fancy and awful jargonny word for saying the feeling of practice really different among these three. So if you look at deliberate practice, it's that which kids found to be the most effortful of the three kinds of practice and the least enjoyable. Finally, we found that of all the personality traits that we looked at, grit was the best predictor of how much deliberate practice you'd actually
现象学——这是一个用来形容练习感受的华丽而可怕的专业术语——在这三种练习中真的很不一样。因此，如果你看看刻意练习，那是孩子们发现这三种练习中最费力且最不愉快的一种。最后，我们发现，在我们考察的所有人格特质中，坚毅是能够实际完成多少刻意练习的最佳预测指标。
get done. So stitching this all together, we see a narrative where very gritty individuals may accumulate more of this very high quality, effortful, not always enjoyable practice. It makes them better and it pays off in their achievement. As I read that paper, I had a moment of great sadness because it felt not just that you were finding that deliberate practice produced these wonderful results, but also what you just said, which is that deliberate practice was the least enjoyable part of the practice. We would like to think that people who work hard are doing it partly because they just really enjoyed what they're doing and that it's enjoyable to be working hard, but you're finding something that's much more, I don't know if the word is Calvinist, but the Puritans would approve of this message,
把这一切缝合在一起，我们看到这样一个叙事：非常坚毅的个人可能会积累更多这种高质量、费力且并非总是令人愉快的练习。这让他们变得更好，并在他们的成就中得到回报。当我阅读那篇论文时，我感到一阵巨大的悲伤，因为不仅觉得你发现刻意练习产生了这些美妙的结果，而且正如你刚才所说的那样，刻意练习是练习中最不愉快的部分。我们愿意认为努力工作的人这样做部分是因为他们真的很喜欢他们正在做的事情，并且努力工作是令人愉快的，但你发现了一些更像是——我不知道这个词是不是加尔文主义者，但清教徒会赞同这个信息——
the idea that very, very hard work that's painful, boring, difficult, unpleasant, yields great rewards. Yeah, there's a lot of nuance to this question of, you know, is it awful? Is it, there's a kind of paraphrasing of Aristotle that the roots of knowledge are bitter, only the fruit is sweet. I mean, that is certainly, you know, one way to read the results of the Spelling Bee Study. But I just want to get a little more nuance in that, because I think you're now, Shankar, the frontier
那种非常非常痛苦、无聊、困难、令人不快但能带来巨大回报的艰苦工作的想法。是的，关于这个问题有很多细微的差别，（你知道的）它是可怕的吗？是对亚里士多德的一种释义，即知识的根是苦的，只有果实是甜的。我的意思是，这当然是（你知道的）解读拼字比赛研究结果的一种方式。但我只是想在其中加入一点细微差别，因为尚卡尔，我认为你现在处在我所知的科学前沿，也真正处于科学所知的边缘。我认为这是一个关于它是否必须如此，还是只是经常如此的辩论。我要说的是，当我与世界级运动员以及在写作或其他领域的顶尖人物交谈时，
of what I know, and I think really of what science knows. I think it's a debate about whether it has to be that way or is just often that way. I will say that when I talk to world-class athletes and people who are at the top of their game in terms of writing or in other domains. Many, many, many of them will express this kind of, yes, it is bitter, but there's this other part of it that I love, that's sweet. It's more of a means to an end,
许许多多的人都会表达这种看法：是的，它是苦的，但还有另一部分是我所热爱的，它是甜的。这更像是一个达到目的的手段，
but I also am hearing some contrary voices, and so that's where we really wanna understand, because if we can make the hardest, most effortful and most effective practice into an experience that is more palatable than I think that we'll go a really long way towards getting people to do more of it. Angela talked about the source of her own grip. It came from her dad at the family breakfast table. Being Asian by upbringing, my dad would often say things like,
但我也听到了一些相反的声音，所以这正是我们真正想要了解的地方，因为如果我们能把最艰难、最费力、最有效的练习变成一种比现在更能让人接受的体验，那么我认为我们在促使人们做更多此类练习方面将会大有作为。安吉拉谈到了她自己坚毅的来源。它来自她家庭早餐桌上的父亲。由于亚洲的成长背景，我父亲经常会说这样的话：
life is suffering. I mean, he would just say it out of the blue. Breakfast, please pass the know, life is suffering. I mean, he would just sort of say it out of the blue. Like breakfast, you know, it's like, please pass the milk, life is suffering. And I think there is a part of grit, which is like dealing with that, you know? It's, you know, whatever color you are, whatever socioeconomic status you are, whatever you want to do with your life,
生活就是受苦。我的意思是，他会毫无征兆地突然说出来。早餐，请把——你知道的，生活就是受苦。我的意思是，他会毫无征兆地突然说出来。就像早餐一样，（你知道的）就像是，请把牛奶递过来，生活就是受苦。我想坚毅的一部分，就像是应对那种情况一样，你知道吗？这是（你知道的）无论你是什么肤色，无论你的社会经济地位如何，无论你想用你的生活做什么，
you know, there's going to be some amount of friction to overcome to really get somewhere. On the other hand, I just want to say this too, because I think it often gets lost in, I just want to say this too, because I think it often gets lost in that one syllable that I call this thing, which is that there's nobody that I've ever interviewed who I would consider a paragon of grit who does not passionately,
（你知道的）要真正取得成就，总会有一定数量的阻力需要克服。另一方面，我也想说这一点，因为我认为这经常在——我只想说这一点，因为我认为这经常在我称之为这个东西的那个单音节词中被忽略，那就是我采访过的任何一个我称之为坚毅典范的人，没有一个不充满激情地、
like ardently, love what they do and get a thrill from it, get a sort of visceral and intrinsic satisfaction from thinking about it, from doing it. No chef that I've ever interviewed, no musician, no academic, no CEO. So we have to reconcile these two accounts, and I think they're both true, and I think it might be reconciled in the fact that that CEO who loves what they do might not love 20% of what they do, but they love the overall project.
热烈地热爱他们所做的事情，并从中获得兴奋感，从思考它、做它中获得一种内脏般的、内在的满足感。我采访过的任何一个厨师、任何一个音乐家、任何一个学者、任何一个首席执行官都是如此。所以我们必须调和这两种说法，我认为它们都是对的，并且它可能在这样一个事实中得到调和：那位热爱自己工作的首席执行官可能并不喜欢他们工作的20%，但他们热爱整个项目。
Routy gains the Olympic swimmer who actually was, you know, subsequent to spits, but, you know, great American swimmer Gold Medalist and a world record holder in the freestyle said that he loved swimming and you could feel it in his voice when you talk to him. But then I said, well, what was practiced like? He's like, oh, what is waking up at four in the morning, walking in the dark in the cold in a bathing suit, to jump into a pool and to push yourself physically to the point of pain, like not fun, but I love swimming.
罗蒂·盖恩斯是一位奥运游泳运动员（实际上是在施皮茨之后，但也是伟大的美国游泳运动员、金牌得主和自由泳世界纪录保持者），他说他热爱游泳，当你和她交谈时，你能在他的声音中感受到这一点。但随后我说，那练习是什么样的？他就像是，哦，什么是早上四点醒来，在黑暗寒冷中穿着泳衣走出去，跳进泳池，把自己的身体推向痛苦的边缘——一点也不好玩，但我热爱游泳。
You talked a second ago about how as members of the audience, we derived a certain pleasure from imagining that performers are naturally gifted, that the genius comes effortlessly. And I'm wondering at some level, if the same thing is also true in our observations of people who are gritty, that we want to see some people as just being naturally gritty. We say Angela Duckworth is a gritty person. If she stopped doing psychology today and started doing something else tomorrow, she would
你刚才提到，作为观众，我们从想象表演者天生有天赋、天才不费吹灰之力中获得某种快乐。我在想，在某种程度上，当我们观察那些坚毅的人时，是否也是如此，我们希望把有些人看作是天生坚毅的。我们说安吉拉·达克沃斯是一个坚毅的人。如果她今天停止做心理学，明天开始做别的事情，她也会
excel at that, and we can marvel at Angela because Angela just has this quality of grittiness about her. And this leads us to a depressing idea, which is that grit really is the domain of just a few people who happen to have it. Is that true? I don't believe that grit isn't either you have it or you don't. I don't believe that it's entirely genetic. You know, you have the gene for grit or you don't have the gene for grit. I don't believe that it's entirely genetic. You have the gene for grid, or you don't have the gene for grid. I don't believe that whatever your grid is today means that that's what your grid is going to be tomorrow. Now in terms of what you could do then,
在那方面表现出色，我们可以对安吉拉感到惊叹，因为安吉拉身上恰好具有这种坚毅的品质。这就引出了一个令人沮丧的想法，那就是坚毅确实只是那些碰巧拥有它的少数人的领域。那是真的吗？我不相信坚毅是“要么你拥有它，要么你没有”。我不相信它完全是基因决定的。（你知道的）你有坚毅的基因，或者你没有坚毅的基因。我不相信它完全是基因决定的。你有坚毅的基因，或者你没有坚毅的基因。我不相信无论你今天的坚毅程度如何，就意味着你明天的坚毅程度也会是这样。现在就你能做什么而言，
if it's true that there's a window here, there's something that we can do about our own grid, I believe that so many things that we would call character or virtue really are as both William James and as Aristotle said, habits, and then you could ask, like, where does the habit of being passionate and persevering about something come from? I really think that you can trace the origins of grit
如果这里确实存在一个窗口，我们对自己的坚毅可以做点什么的话，我相信我们称之为品格或美德的许多东西，正如威廉·詹姆斯和亚里士多德所说的那样，确实是习惯，然后你可能会问，比如，对某事充满热情和坚持的习惯从何而来？我真的认为你可以把坚毅的起源追溯到
to four psychological assets, which again, themselves can be acquired, practiced, cultivated. One is an interest. I mean, you can't be gritty about something that you're not interested in. So understanding your own interest, cultivating them, deepening interest. The second thing is the capacity to do deliberate practice.
四个心理资产，而这些资产本身是可以获得的、练习的和培养的。一个是兴趣。我的意思是，对于你不感兴趣的事情，你是不可能坚毅的。所以理解你自己的兴趣，培养它们，深化兴趣。第二件事是进行刻意练习的能力。
Part of that is knowing what deliberate practice is and what it's not and being willing to do it. Part of it is habit. The third thing that I find that's a psychological asset of gritty people that I think can be acquired or cultivated is a sense of purpose. I mean, there isn't a single paragon of grit that I've interviewed. And I'm not saying that there aren't those out there who might be this way.
其中一部分是知道什么是刻意练习，什么不是刻意练习，并且愿意去做。一部分是习惯。我发现坚毅的人的第三个心理资产是可以获得或培养的，那就是目标感。我的意思是，我采访过的每一个坚毅的典范都不是这样的。我并不是说外面没有这样的人。
But I've interviewed person after person who I think exemplifies passion and perseverance. And to a one, they have a sense of how what they do day in day out, is meaningful and beneficial to people who are not them, a beyond the self outlook, a beyond the self purpose. And you might think, oh, what about athletes? It's kind of selfish, or even interviewed a wine master named Antonio Golognian, I was thinking, like, what is more selfish than basically tasting wine all day, and writing about it.
但我采访了一个又一个我认为体现了热情与坚持的人。毫无例外，他们都有这样一种意识：他们日复一日所做的事情是如何对不是他们自己的人有意义且有益的，一种超越自我的视角，一种超越自我的目标。你可能会想，哦，那运动员呢？这有点自私，我甚至采访过一位名叫安东尼奥·加洛尼的葡萄酒大师，我想，还有什么比整天品尝葡萄酒并撰写关于它的文章更自私的呢？
And he said, I wake up every day with a mission and he can see he's like, I know I'm not curing cancer, but I really believe that if I can help people appreciate wine, it will enrich their lives in a small way. So a sense of purpose, I think, can be cultivated. And then finally, there's hope. And we haven't talked too much about that, but I think the hope to keep going when hope seems lost. I mean, you can trace this back to growth mindset, to having an optimistic,
他说，我带着使命醒来，你可以看出他说：我知道我不是在治愈癌症，但我真的相信，如果我能帮助人们欣赏葡萄酒，它会在微小的方面丰富他们的生活。所以目标感，我认为是可以培养的。最后，还有希望。我们没有过多地讨论这一点，但我认为当希望似乎破灭时，要抱有继续前进的希望。我的意思是，你可以把这追溯到成长型思维，对消极事件有乐观的、
explanatory style for negative events, but I do believe hope and purpose and a capacity to practice and interest all these things can be cultivated. Angela Sashi works hard to cultivate grit in her own children. I'll say for both of my daughters, you know, they, you know, themselves struggle, I think as all children do, even daughters of someone who studies grit, to do things that are frustrating and hard, to do things to come home from a ballet class, and to know in your heart that the girl next to you
解释风格，但我确实相信希望、目标、练习的能力和兴趣，所有这些东西都是可以培养的。安吉拉确实努力在她自己的孩子身上培养坚毅。我要为我的两个女儿说，（你知道的）她们自己也在挣扎，我认为就像所有孩子一样，甚至是研究坚毅之人的女儿，去做那些令人沮丧和困难的事情，从芭蕾舞课上回到家里，并且内心深知道你旁边的那个人
was better than you, right? And to stay motivated and to stay engaged, and to like still try to love ballet and come back to the class the next day. You know, that was really hard for them. The thing that actually like ended up being maybe most useful in our family, my husband and I, we called the hard thing rule. And what we did was we said, look, you know, from a very early age, we knew that we wanted our kids to develop the capacity for perseverance and to develop a passion. We didn't want to like, to rob them of the opportunity
比你更好，对吧？并且保持动力，保持投入，并且仍然试图热爱芭蕾舞，第二天回到课堂。你知道的，这对我女儿们来说真的很难。最终在我们家里可能证明最有用的一件事情，我和我丈夫，我们称之为“困难事情规则”。我们所做的是，我们说，看，（你知道的）从很小的时候起，我们就知道我们希望我们的孩子培养坚持的能力并培养热情。我们不想剥夺他们
to really direct themselves. So we said, everybody in our family has to do a hard thing. That's the first of three parts. So a hard thing in our family means it requires deliberate practice on a regular basis. So kind of signing up for pottery class where you just have fun once a week.
真正自我指导的机会。所以我们说，我们家的每个人都必须做一件困难的事情。这是三个部分中的第一部分。所以在我们家里，一件困难的事情意味着它需要定期进行刻意练习。所以那种报名参加每周只玩一次的陶艺班，
That's not a hard thing because there's no deliberate. But doing viola, or going out for the track team, that is. So my husband said, I'm a real estate developer. Trust me, it's a hard thing every day. I said the same thing about my career. And then my daughter is actually the younger one, Lucy, really struggled to find something that she really wanted
那不是一件困难的事情，因为没有刻意练习。但练习中提琴，或者参加田径队，那就是。所以我的丈夫说：我是一名房地产开发商，相信我，每天都是一件困难的事情。我对我的职业也这么说。然后我的小女儿露西，确实很难找到一件她真正想要
to do. I'll tell you that the second part of the hard thing rule is that, okay, so the first part is it requires a little practice, it's hard in that way. The second part is you can't quit until the tuition payment is up. You can't quit, you know, in the middle of the seat. You can't quit until the final track meet. You cannot quit. So it gave, I think, our kids that little push to say like, I don't want to do it today, but I'm not going to quit in the middle.
去做的事情。我要告诉你的是，“困难事情规则”的第二部分是，好吧，所以第一部分是它需要一点练习，在这方面很难。第二部分是你不能在学费付清之前放弃。你不能（你知道的）在学期中途放弃。你不能在最后一场田径比赛之前放弃。你绝对不能放弃。所以这给了我们的孩子们一点推动力去说：我今天不想做这件事，但我不会在中间放弃。
I'm going to quit at a natural ending point. And the third thing, really, to get back to that intrinsic motivation was that, yes, you can quit at the end of the semester when the tuition payment is up, but not until you've figured out a new hard thing, so you have to kind of go from one right to the other, and nobody picks any of these hard things except for you. So I did let my kids, even when they were in kindergarten, pick their hard thing.
我要在一个自然的终点放弃。第三件事，真正回归到内在动机，那就是，是的，你可以在学期结束时学费付清时放弃，但前提是你已经想好了一项新的困难事情，所以你必须从一个直接过渡到另一个，而且除了你之外，没有人挑选这些困难的事情。所以我确实让我的孩子们，甚至在他们上幼儿园的时候，选择他们困难的事情。
And yes, they had to stick with it until this semester was over, and yes, it had to require deliberate practice. So I feel like, did we do it perfectly? Is it the best rule? I don't know, but I think it reconciles like the kind of tiger mom, this intuition that we have to assist our kids
是的，他们必须坚持下去，直到学期结束，是的，它必须需要刻意练习。所以我觉得，我们做得完美吗？这是最好的规则吗？我不知道，但我觉得它调和了像虎妈那样的做法——这种直觉，即我们必须协助我们的孩子们
to do things that they don't want to do in the moment, but also preserves their autonomy, which I think is so important. Angela Duckworth is a psychologist at the University of Pennsylvania. She's also founder and scientific director of the character lab. Her new book, Grit, the Power of Passion and Persever and perseverance is out this spring. OK, so grit is clearly great. It helps you get stuff done be successful. But is it possible to be too gritty?
去做他们当下不想做的事情——同时也保持了他们的自主性，我认为这非常重要。安吉拉·达克沃斯是宾夕法尼亚大学的心理学教授。她也是“品格实验室”的创始人和科学主任。她的新书《坚毅：热情与坚持的力量》于今年春天出版。好吧，所以坚毅显然很棒。它能帮你完成事情并取得成功。但有没有可能过于坚毅了呢？
Sometimes people with high grit might not do the logical rational thing because their grit compels them to keep going. When we come back, the dark side of grit. So I've always thought that grit was a wonderful thing. Something I've wanted to cultivate in myself, something I wanted to pass along to my daughter. That is, until I talked to Gayle Lucas. My name is Gayle Lucas and I am a senior research associate at the Institute for Creative Technologies, which is part of University of Southern California.
有时，具有高坚毅度的人可能不会做符合逻辑、理性的事，因为他们的坚毅驱使他们坚持下去。当我们回来时，我们将探讨坚毅阴暗的一面。所以我一直认为坚毅是一件美妙的事情。这是我想在自己身上培养的东西，也是我想传授给女儿的东西。直到我与盖尔·卢卡斯交谈。我叫盖尔·卢卡斯，我是创意技术研究所的高级研究员，该研究所是南加州大学的一部分。
From an early age, Gayle knew she was a very gritty individual. My mom often talks about this time when she made a learning book for me when I was pretty young about five or six and we were at the beach and this was something she wanted me to do during the summer to continue my learning. And I got so into it that I didn't stop to go to the beach or do anything fun with the neighborhood kids. I just sat there and I finished my book because I started it and I pushed right through it.
从很小的时候起，盖尔就知道自己是一个非常坚毅的人。我妈妈经常谈起这样一件事：当我大约五六岁还很小的时候，她为我制作了一本学习册，我们在海滩上，这是她希望我在夏天做的事情，以继续我的学习。我太投入了，以至于我没有停下来去海滩或和邻居的孩子们做任何有趣的事情。我只是坐在那里，完成了我的书，因为我开始了，我就一路坚持到底。
Gail's grit has certainly benefited her in many ways. She's had a successful academic career. But also, I think I missed out on the beach a little bit. So when Gail Lucas went on to study the potential downside of grit, she knew something about this already. Sometimes people with high grit might not do the logical, rational thing because their grit compels them to keep going. sometimes people with high grit might not do the logical rational thing because their grit compels them to keep going.
盖尔的坚毅无疑在很多方面让她受益匪浅。她拥有成功的学术生涯。但同时，我也觉得我稍微错过了一些海滩时光。因此，当盖尔·卢卡斯去研究坚毅潜在的消极面时，她对此已经有所了解。有时，具有高坚毅度的人可能不会做符合逻辑、理性的事，因为他们的坚毅驱使他们坚持下去。有时，具有高坚毅度的人可能不会做符合逻辑、理性的事，因为他们的坚毅驱使他们坚持下去。
In one study gale conducted, participants were asked to play an online game that presented them with a choice. They could quit and get a dollar or keep playing for the chance to win two dollars. However, if they lost, they would get nothing. Gritty people and non-gritty people both made the rational choice to keep going if they were winning because their chances of getting two dollars were looking pretty good. But if they were losing the grittier people were more likely to make that choice to stay in the game risk not getting the dollar to win the two dollars even though they were losing and it was a very low likelihood that
在盖尔进行的一项研究中，参与者被要求玩一个在线游戏，游戏中给他们提供了一个选择。他们可以退出并获得一美元，或者继续玩以获得赢得两美元的机会。然而，如果他们输了，他们将一无所有。坚毅的人和不坚毅的人如果正在赢钱，都会做出继续下去的理性选择，因为他们获得两美元的机会看起来相当不错。但如果他们正在输钱，更坚毅的人更有可能做出留在游戏中的选择——冒着拿不到那一美元的风险去赢得两美元——尽管他们当时正在输，而且最终能够成功的可能性非常低。
they were gonna end up pulling it off at the end. Gay Lucas and her colleagues also showed how being gritty might make it hard for you to take timed exams like the SAT. That's because you're supposed to give up when you don't know the answer to a question. You just skip it, go on to the next question. So we made by definition some problems that couldn't be solved. We used an anagrams task, so unscramble words, and this is standard in some of the psychology literature where there's these
盖尔·卢卡斯和她的同事们还展示了过于坚毅如何让你很难参加像SAT这样的限时考试。那是因为当你不知道某个问题的答案时，你应该放弃。你只需跳过它，进入下一个问题。所以我们根据定义制作了一些无法解决的问题。我们使用了变位词任务，也就是重新组合打乱的字母，这在一些心理学文献中是很标准的，其中使用了一些
anagrams that are used that are unsolvable. They don't scramble to any word whatsoever. And so we knew which items were worth persisting on, the ones that were solvable, and the ones that were not worth persisting on because there's no way you could actually solve them. And what we showed was that grittier individuals weren't able to get through as many and they were persisting on these ones that were unsolvable to a greater extent than the less gritty individuals. And so really what you're finding then is that the grittier individuals, they stick at these difficult problems so long that they actually hurt themselves. Exactly. And that's something that we hope people take away from our research and knowing that this is again strategy and taking strategic choices on when to move on to something else is what
无法解决的变位词。它们不会重新组合成任何单词。所以我们知道哪些题目值得坚持——那些可以解决的题目，以及哪些不值得坚持，因为你根本无法解决它们。我们发现的是，更坚毅的个人无法通过那么多的题目，并且他们在这些无法解决的题目上坚持的程度要大于不够坚毅的个人。所以你真正发现的是，更坚毅的人，他们在这些困难的问题上坚持了那么久，以至于他们实际上伤害了自己。 exatamente。这也是我们希望人们从我们的研究中汲取的东西，并且知道这再次关乎策略，在何时转向其他事情上做出战略选择是
we would like to teach. We think gritty people should learn alongside becoming gritty and being gritty. It's certainly we don't want them to abandon being gritty, but we'd like them to see the benefits that sometimes stopping it with something and going on and moving on is the more beneficial path. Geltz as she knows from personal experience, how grit can be harmful. I was married and I stuck in that relationship for nine years. I ended up getting a divorce and I persisted in that relationship to the very final end
我们想要教导的。我们认为坚毅的人应该在变得坚毅和保持坚毅的同时进行学习。我们当然不希望他们放弃坚毅，但我们希望他们看到这样一个好处：有时停下某件事并继续前行、向前迈进才是更有益的道路。盖尔说，她从个人经验中知道坚毅如何具有破坏性。我曾结过婚，我在那段关系中坚持了九年。我最终离婚了，我在那段关系中坚持到了最后一刻，
and perhaps longer than was good for either my partner or myself. Gail Sashie was so gritty about her marriage, she didn't see leaving as an option. And so now in hindsight I can see that maybe I did more damage by staying in a relationship that wasn't the right one longer than I should have. Our society looks down on quitting. We don't stop to ask whether it's sometimes a good idea to quit. Gail applied the same drive and determination she had as a child, focused on academics at the beach to her marriage.
并且坚持的时间可能比对我的伴侣或我自己都有益的时间还要长。盖尔对她的婚姻如此坚毅，以至于她没有把离开视为一种选择。所以现在回想起来，我可以看到，也许我通过停留在一段不对的婚姻中比我应该的时间更长，造成了更多的伤害。我们的社会看不起放弃。我们没有停下来去问放弃有时是否是个好主意。盖尔将她小时候在海滩上专注于学业的那种驱动力和决心应用到了她的婚姻中。
There's a stigma around getting divorced. There's a stigma around getting divorced. There's a stigma around saying, well, I quit this. There's a stigma around choosing a different job and saying I wasn't cut out for this job. And so it's hard as a gritty person to not just go along with that because everything supports that, rather than really taking that look as am I hurting myself?
离婚有一种污名。离婚有一种污名。说“好吧，我放弃了这个”有一种污名。选择一份不同的工作并说“我不适合这份工作”有一种污名。所以作为坚毅的人，很难不随波逐流，因为一切都在支持这一点，而不是真正审视自己：我是在伤害自己吗？
Am I going about this the wrong way? And it's only after having such big failures, having such big instances where I hurt myself and people that I really loved and cared about that I could start opening my eyes and seeing that, that I didn't make the connection between the little child on the book and focused on that to my marriage,
我是不是用错误的方式对待这件事？直到经历了如此大的失败，经历了如此多的自己伤害了自己以及自己真正深爱和关心的人的实例之后，我才能开始睁开眼睛看到这一点，我没有把书本上那个专注的小孩与我的婚姻联系起来，
because everybody else and everything else was telling me in society that it's good to stick with what you're doing and don't give up. So there really are two kinds of grit. One is the good kind, it overcomes obstacles, fights through distractions. Albert Einstein and Mark Spitz and Angela Duckworth herself are shining examples. The other kind of grit is obstinate, against all evidence to the contrary it presses on, it ignores signals that failure is imminent, digs deeper into the hole. Let's give this grit another name, stubbornness. But here's the thing, I don't think it's easy to tell whether you're looking at grit or stubbornness before you know how something
因为社会上的其他人和其他所有事情都在告诉我，坚持你正在做的事情是好的，不要放弃。所以确实有两种坚毅。一种是好的那种，它克服障碍，冲破干扰。阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦、马克·施皮茨和安吉拉·达克沃斯本人就是光辉的榜样。另一种坚毅是顽固的，在所有相反的证据面前依然向前推进，它无视失败即将来临的信号，在洞里挖得更深。让我们给这种坚毅起另一个名字：固执。但问题是，在你知道事情如何收场之前，我认为很难判断你看到的是坚毅还是固执。
turns out. If I try my hand at the piano and don't get very far after a few years, should I demonstrate grit and press on, or should I acknowledge my lack of musical talent and tell myself I'm banging my head against a war. It's the same thing with those volunteers in Gayle Lucas' experiment. They're given unsolvable anagrams, but the thing is, they don't know the anagrams are unsolvable. There are certainly difficult problems that can be solved if you stick to them. I found it striking that both Gayle Lucas and Angela Duckworth talked about grit in the
如果我尝试弹钢琴，几年后没有取得多大进展，我应该表现出坚毅并继续前进，还是应该承认我缺乏音乐天赋，并告诉自己我是在以卵击石？盖尔·卢卡斯实验中的那些志愿者也是如此。他们被赋予了无法解决的变位词，但问题是，他们不知道这些变位词是无法解决的。当然有一些困难的问题，如果你坚持下去是可以解决的。我发现惊人的是，盖尔·卢卡斯和安吉拉·达克沃斯都在婚姻的语境下谈论了坚毅，却得出了相反的结论。盖尔觉得她的固执让她在一段糟糕的婚姻中停留的时间超过了她本该停留的时间。但安吉拉告诉我，坚毅预示着稳定的婚姻。
context of marriage, but came to opposite conclusions, Gail felt her stubbornness kept her in a bad marriage longer than she should have stayed. But Angela told me that grit predicts stable marriages. When two people are gritty, they are likely to weather ups and downs. Is stubbornness just the name we give to grit when things turn out badly? The same thing is true when you look at historical figures. Isaac Newton revolutionized the world of mathematics and physics.
当两个人都有坚毅的品质时，他们很可能经受住起伏。固执只是我们在事情结果糟糕时赋予坚毅的名字吗？当你观察历史人物时，情况也是如此。艾萨克·牛顿彻底改变了数学和物理学世界。
He exemplified grit in inventing calculus. But Newton also wasted much of his life on alchemy. He spent hours on what Angela Duckworth would call deliberate practice trying to turn elements into gold or looking for hidden scientific truths in scripture. Work by the psychologist Philip Tetlock and others suggest that grit and stubbornness might be two sides of the same coin. The people who press on when times are hard and the people who stubbornly bang their heads
他在发明微积分时体现了坚毅。但牛顿也将他生命中的大部分时间浪费在了炼金术上。他花了几小时进行安吉拉·达克沃斯所说的刻意练习，试图将元素变成黄金，或者在经文中寻找隐藏的科学真理。心理学家菲利普·泰特洛克和其他人的研究表明，坚毅和固执可能是同一枚硬币的两面。那些在艰难时期坚持下去的人，以及那些固执地以卵击石的人
against a wall, these might be the same people. We call them gritty or call them stubborn after we know how things turned out in the end. The Hidden Brain podcast is produced by Karam Agra-Kalasun, Maggie Pennman and Max Nestrak. Find more of Hidden Brain on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram. Sign up for our newsletter by emailing us at hiddenbrain at npr.org. I'm Shankar Vitantam and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
面对逆境时，这可能是同一批人。在结果揭晓后，我们称他们为坚韧或顽强。Hidden Brain 播客由 Karam Agra-Kalasun、Maggie Pennman 和 Max Nestrak 制作。在 Facebook、Twitter 和 Instagram 上关注 Hidden Brain 的更多内容。发送电子邮件至 hiddenbrain@npr.org 订阅我们的新闻通讯。我是 Shankar Vitantam，这里是 NPR。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。